hey this is presh tolwalker
mathematical competitions date back to
ancient times
to quote an Indian poem just as the sun
outshines the Stars the math wizard
eclipses others by solving mathematical
problems in public
in modern times the very first
International mathematical Olympiad was
held in Romania in 1959 and had seven
countries
the IMO has since expanded to over 100
countries across five continents
I'm sure its Founders would be delighted
that decades later people around the
world are searching YouTube just for
Olympiad problems to give themselves a
mathematical challenge
this question comes from the 1959 IMO
and its problem number two
for one real values of X is the square
root of the quantity X plus the square
root of the quantity 2x minus one
plus the square root of the quantity x
minus the square root of the quantity 2x
minus 1 all equal to a
given
different conditions part A A is equal
to square root of 2 b a is equal to one
C A is equal to two
we're only non-negative real numbers are
admitted for square roots
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
I think this is a delightful problem
because while it is very challenging a
motivated student who works step by step
would be able to work it out
so let's get started
let's focus on the domain
only non-negative real numbers are
admitted for square roots
so we need everything under square roots
to be non-negative numbers
here we have the square root of 2x minus
one
we need that to be a non-negative number
so zero is less than or equal to 2x
minus one one is less than or equal to
2x so X is greater than or equal to
one-half
now let's look over here we have X plus
the square root of something we know
that the square root of that thing will
be a non-negative number we're adding X
which is greater than one half so the
entire thing is going to be a
non-negative number no problem what
about here we have x minus the square
root of 2x minus one so we're
subtracting a non-negative number so we
need to make sure that X is greater than
or equal to the square root of 2x minus
1. now since X is greater than or equal
to one half the square root of 2x minus
1 will be greater than or equal to zero
so we'll safely Square both sides of the
equation so x squared is greater than or
equal to 2x minus one that means x
squared minus two X plus one is greater
than or equal to 0. now we can factor to
a perfect square we have the square of x
minus 1 is greater than or equal to zero
but this equation will always be true
because the square of a real number will
always be something that's greater than
or equal to zero
so now we're set on these conditions
furthermore we have the square root of
something plus the square root of
something is equal to a we know that
each of these square roots is a
non-negative number we're adding two
non-negative numbers so we know that a
is going to be a non-negative number so
a is greater than or equal to zero
so now that these conditions are set
let's analyze the equation to eliminate
the square roots let's Square both sides
of the equation
so first we have the square of the first
square root that will eliminate this
square root then we add the square of
the next square root that eliminates the
next square root and finally we add two
times the product of the square roots
this is equal to a squared
now the square root of 2x minus 1 will
cancel out with its opposite
under this square root we have a
non-negative number under this square
root we have a non-negative number so
the square root of a non-negative number
multiplied by the square root of a
non-negative number is equal to the
square root of the product of the two
numbers
so this simplifies to be 2x plus 2 times
the square root of the product of these
binomials this is all equal to a squared
now furthermore we have X plus some term
multiplied by x minus the same term so
this will work out to be a difference of
squares this will be x squared minus the
quantity 2x minus 1.
we can simplify under the square root
now x squared minus 2x plus 1 is exactly
equal to the square of x minus 1.
so we the square root of the square of x
minus 1 this will work out to be the
absolute value of x minus 1.
we can then divide both sides of the
equation by 2 giving X plus the absolute
value of x minus 1 is equal to a squared
divided by 2.
now we have an equation with an absolute
value term so we will work this out in
cases
in one case let's suppose that X is
greater than one
then the absolute value of x minus 1 is
equal to x minus 1. so the equation
becomes X Plus x minus 1 is equal to a
squared over 2.
so 2x minus 1 is equal to a squared over
two two x is equal to a squared over 2
plus 1 and X is equal to a squared over
four plus one half
this means that X is equal to a squared
plus two all over four
so we'll put this case to the side and
now we'll consider the other case that X
is less than or equal to 1. this means
the absolute value of x minus 1 is equal
to 1 minus X substituting in we have X
plus one minus X is equal to a squared
over two the X terms cancel out one is
equal to a squared over two two is equal
to a squared now a is greater than or
equal to zero so that means a is equal
to the positive square root of 2.
so we've worked out these cases
furthermore we know that X is greater
than or equal to one-half so we can
combine that with the first inequality
so we have X is less than or equal to
one and it's greater than or equal to
one-half in that case a is equal to
square root of two
now if x is greater than one we know
it's already greater than or equal to
one half so we don't need to add
anything to this inequality
so now we will graph a as a function of
x
so suppose that one-half is less than or
equal to X is less than one in that case
a is equal to square root of two so we
can graph it like this and we have a
closed interval
now what if instead X is greater than
one half
so what would happen over here x is
equal to a squared plus two all over
four so X is equal to a squared plus two
over four will look something like a
parabola so let's get a sense over the
parabola starts and what it looks like
now if x approaches 1 and we set that
equal to a squared plus 2 all over four
we solve that a is equal to square root
of two
so this is exactly this point one comma
square root of two where this line
segment ends
then if we set X is equal to 3 over 2 we
can set that equal to a squared plus 2
all over 4 and we would get that a is
equal to 2. so we have this point over
here three halves comma two
we now want a parabola that will be a
curve segment between these two points
so it'll look something like this
so now that we have this graph we can
solve the problem
so part A A is equal to square root of
two
so we will Mark the line a is equal to
square root of 2 and we can see that
there is a solution in X so X will be
the interval one-half is less than or
equal to X is less than or equal to one
that's the answer to part a
Part B A is equal to 1.
so here a is equal to one we see it
doesn't intersect the graph of this
function there is no solution there's no
value of x for which this is true
finally a is equal to 2. so here we have
a is equal to two and we see there's
exactly one intersection so we have X is
equal to three over two
so that's the answer to this question
what a wonderful and challenging problem
from the first mathematical Olympiad
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign